Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, Nummer 8.
Folge Nummer 8.
Und die letzte in diesem Jahr, oder? Ja.
Vorausgesetzt, wir machen nichts zum Kongress.
Das stimmt, vorausgesetzt wir machen nichts zum Kongress. Also die letzte regelmäßige.
Genau, die letzte reguläre Folge.
Tja, ist irgendwas passiert?
Ja, natürlich, es ist wie immer was passiert. Wir haben uns aber vorgenommen, diesmal etwas kurz zu fassen.
Kleiner Witz zu Weihnachten.
Also das erste, was so nennenswert ist, vielleicht ist es auch, weil es nicht nennenswert ist, nennenswert. Frau Schröder stellt ihren Plan vor, ein Internet-Kinderschutzzentrum.
Also unsere tolle neue Familienministerin.
So neu ist sie, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr, oder?
So richtig neu ist sie nicht mehr.
Sie möchte ein Internet-Kinderschutzzentrum haben.
Ein Internet-Kinderschutzzentrum? Wer soll da vor wem geschützt werden?
Ja, das ist irgendwie die Frage. Sie möchte die Prävention und Opferschutz beim Cybermobbing bieten und natürlich auch irgendwie Missbrauchsdarstellungen bekämpfen, Grooming bekämpfen, gleichzeitig aber möchte sie irgendwie auch Jugendbeteiligung haben und irgendwie eine Kampagne für Jugendschutzprogramme.
Moment, Grooming?
Grooming war dieses, was auch im Tatort Internet angeprangert wurde, also das, bevor es irgendwie wirkliches Flirten wird, Erwachsene mit Kindern sprechen und eventuell ein Flirt anbahnen. Also letztendlich so ein etwas komischer Tatbestand, dass also ein, sagen wir mal, ein älterer Mann in einem Chatroom mit einem Kind spricht und es aber noch nicht irgendwie dazugekommen ist, dass da irgendwas wirklich Schlimmes passiert, sondern das angebahnt wird. Das ist das Grooming und das, also so diese Grauzone. Es könnte also sein, dass da jemand etwas Böses macht oder so.
Das muss auch schon alles verhindert werden.
Das muss auch verhindert werden. Und fragt man sich natürlich, wie möchte sie das machen? Und da hat sie diese schöne Idee des Notrufs-Buttons. Jetzt muss ich ganz kurz kurz schauen, wo ich das gefunden habe. Nicht, dass ich jetzt wieder irgendwas Böses unterstelle. Genau, also ein Notruf-Button, der soll da sein. Und dann können Kinder und Jugendliche Hilfe und Beratung in allen Situationen erhalten, die sie als Bedrohung erleben. Jetzt fragt man sich, wo dieser Button sein soll. Der könnte an verschiedenen Stellen sein. Man könnte sich vorstellen, dass der auf der Tastatur mit drauf ist. Dass der in der Webseite mit eingebaut ist, ähnlich wie so ein Flatter- oder Facebook-Button. Man sagt so, oh hier, gefällt mir nicht, so ein Notruf. Kommt der Kinderschutzbund, weil dieses Internet-Kinderschutzzentrum soll ja in Zusammenarbeit mit Staat, Wirtschaft und Opferschützern gemacht werden, und irgendwie stellt man sich also vor, dass es diesen Knopf geben soll. Und jetzt natürlich die Frage, wenn ich bei illegalen Anbietern bin, ob die auch diesen Knopf darunter machen. Also sagen wir mal, irgendwie ein Anbieter, der irgendwas Böses...
Also der Knopf soll sozusagen auf der Webseite, wir reden ja hier wahrscheinlich wieder von Webseiten und nur von Webseiten...
Ich stell mir das so vor. Also ich mein, es ist immer etwas schwierig, deren, das was sie meinen, da auch herauszulesen, weil sie da ja wirklich Menschen, Dinge formulieren, die im Zweifelsfall nicht so viele Ahnung davon haben.
Ja, den Eindruck gewinnt man.
Also in der Webseite eingebaut wäre es ja wirklich so ungefähr das Unsinnigste, was man sich vorstellen kann. Weil jeder, der ernsthaft illegale Inhalte wissentlich irgendwo verbreitet, natürlich diesen Knopf nicht einbinden würde.
Oder zumindest nicht in funktionierender Form.
Genau, man könnte ihn ja auch jederzeit imitieren. Also ja, eben klar, wenn er in der Webseite eingebaut ist, ist es noch das...
Bekloppteste.
Das ist das allerbekloppteste, was ich mir eventuell vorstellen könnte, wie man sowas, also was, wie man es vielleicht machen könnte. Ich will ja jetzt keine Tipps geben, aber ein Browser Plugin erschien mir da persönlich vielleicht noch als das vielversprechendste. Aber dann funktioniert wieder nur im Browser. Aber okay, darüber hinaus wird man eh wahrscheinlich kaum kommen mit dem Knopf.
Ja, und ich meine die Zeit von Browser Plugins, die ist jetzt auch so ein bisschen vorbei.
Ja, aber das wäre dann, also deswegen könnte man das ja jetzt von Regierungsseite dann auch endlich mal machen. Also ein Knopf.
Jetzt muss es keine mehr gibt.
Man stellt sich nach wie vor, also ich weiß auch nicht, wie viele dann aus Spaß auf den Knopf drücken wollen. Diese Idee mit dem Knopf war auch regelmäßig mit irgendwie Behörden, Einschaltungen, Ideen verbunden. Also Ideen kamen, dass man gesagt hat, okay, wir machen diesen Knopf und dann wird das sofort irgendwie, landet das auf einer Liste, wo sich dann Polizisten das anschauen und quasi so eine Art sofort ein Anzeigeformular ausgeführt. Diese Idee gibt es schon ewig und kommt auch immer wieder und sie kommt immer wieder von Menschen, die dann irgendwie in keiner Form in der Lage sind, irgendwie ein überzeugendes Konzept für so einen Knopf zu liefern.
Wie das technisch funktionieren soll. Oder auch nur organisatorisch funktionieren soll.
Organisatorisch, genau, technisch fängt es schon an. Organisatorisch und wenn dann erstmal Nonemis von der Sache hört und die einfach auf jeder Website 180 mal auf den Knopf drücken, wie man beabsichtigt, damit dann umzugehen. Also von vorne bis hinten nicht nachgedacht.
Trotzdem ist das jetzt wieder als Vorschlag auf den Tisch.
Ja, irgendwas muss ja dann immer kommen. Und was, glaube ich, so, wo sie dann sich sehr viel drüber geärgert wurde, ist, dass sie das in ihrer Pressemitteilung bei dem BMFSFJ so ein bisschen so darstellt, als wäre das ein Ergebnis der Dialog-Internet-Reihe. Da haben sie dann immer wieder Leute eingeladen und irgendwie da so eine Art, man könnte sogar sagen, irgendwie so eine Art Bar-Camp-mäßig-Diskussionstische im Kreis und schreibt mal auf den Tisch und dann gehen wir rum. Und da haben sie solche Veranstaltungen gehabt, wo dann eben auch die Netzgemeinde in Anführungszeichen eingeladen war und natürlich auch Vertreter der Wirtschaft, irgendwie so Personen, verschiedene Personen, da irgendwie eingeladen wurden. Und da sagt sie irgendwie, dass das irgendwie so ein bisschen aus diesem, damit ziehe sie Schlüsse aus den Handlungsempfehlungen, die im Dialog Internet innerhalb des Jahres erarbeitet wurden. Und es wurden dann Stimmen laut von Leuten, die da hingegangen sind. Wenn ich mich recht entsinne, waren da so Leute wie der Mario Six, das war da glaube ich auch mal eingeladen, der Mr. Topf. Und solche Leute, die sich dann irgendwie auch zu Wort melden und sagen, da könnten sie sich jetzt aber nicht unbedingt dran erinnern, dass da irgendwie über so ein Nothofknopf gesprochen wurde. Aber wie gesagt, ist auch andererseits wieder relativ uninteressant, weil so etwas ist einfach nicht realisierbar. Das ist völliger Unsinn und tut mir leid. Werden sie nicht hinbekommen? Und wenn, dann wird es auf jeden Fall, wenn sie es versuchen, das irgendwie zu machen, dann wird es auf jeden Fall sehr witzig.
Ja, oder traurig. Ich meine, ich finde das ja grundsätzlich alles nicht schlimm, dass man jetzt versucht, Fluchtmöglichkeiten zu schaffen, Hilfemöglichkeiten anzubieten, aber die dann eben wirklich so direkt in das angeblich so bedrohende Internet selber hineinzusetzen, das widerspricht ja so ein bisschen auch der eigentlichen Logik hier.
Ja, was dann noch so ein bisschen eine Rolle spielt, wo ich eine Frage, der ich so ein bisschen zwiespätig gegenüberstehe, ist, sie möchte also eine Kampagne für Jugendschutzprogramme machen. Es hätte sich also in Umfragen ergeben, dass viele Eltern sagen, dass das ja eigentlich eine tolle Sache wäre oder dass sie sowas gerne hätten für ihre Kinder. Und das aber nur sehr wenige nutzen. Und das erinnerte mich einerseits auch so ein bisschen an die JMS TV, der ja mit, also der Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag, in dem dann auch so Ideen aufkamen, dass man irgendwie Schließ- und Öffnungszeiten für Webseiten verlangen würde und so eine Art Meta-Kennzeichnung verpflichtend einführen würde. Dass man im versteckten Teilen des HTML-Dokuments Altersbegrenzungen reinschreibt. Und die müssen eigenverantwortlich richtig gesetzt sein. Sonst ist man, also wenn ich jetzt quasi ab 18 Seiten da 12 reinschreiben würde, dann würde ich mich also irgendwie der Gefahr aussetzen, irgendwie gerichtlich belangt zu werden. Und nur das würde ja wiederum eine sehr große Rechtsunsicherheit für mich bieten. Sodass ich eigentlich nur dann sicher bin, wenn ich meine Seite ab 18 mache. Und dann könnten wiederum von anderen zuliefernd gegebene Jugendschutzprogramme würden damit ja das Problem umgehen, zumindest für das deutsche Internet, dass der Betreiber selber diese Seiten irgendwie beurteilen müsste. Weil also der Betreiber des Programmes selber die Seiten beurteilen müsste. Weil häufig funktionieren Jugendschutzfilter darüber, dass man also sagt, man macht ein Whitelisting. Das heißt, jede Verbindung ist zu, außer unser Programm hat diese Seite als ungefährlich erkannt. Führt zu dem großen Problem, dass immer kleine Seiten, kleine Blogs, kleinere Dienste überhaupt gar nicht da durchkommen. Wenn man es mit Blacklisting macht, kommt die Firma, die dieses Programm anbietet, der der ganzen Sache nicht hinterher, weil sie irgendwann merken muss, das Internet ist doch relativ groß und wenn man da alles gesehen haben möchte, schafft man das nicht. Das heißt, das war das Problem oder vor dem Problem stehen diese Jugendschutzprogrammanbieter. Und im JMS TV sollte eben unter anderem dafür gesorgt werden, dass man diese Last, das outsourced auf die Betreiber und die quasi verpflichtet. Was ja erstmal vielleicht gar nicht so eine, also die Idee war ja nicht so doof. Nur die Rechtsunsicherheit, die da mit einherging, war natürlich problematisch. Sodass dann eben das hätte dazu geführt, dass jeder seine Seite irgendwie ab 18 hätte machen müssen. Und irgendwie gab es auch kein sinnvolles Konzept dafür, wie denn, sage ich mal, ich eventuell vielleicht unsere Startseite. Und dann ist vielleicht mal, solange nur habe ich vielleicht in einem Blog mal einen Artikel, der ab 16 ist, dann muss ich eigentlich unsere Startseite ab 16 machen und diesen Artikel. Aber unsere Startseite nur solange, wie dieser Artikel darauf ist. Und irgendwie gab es da kein sinnvolles.
Ja, die praktische Umsetzbarkeit im Netz ist einfach immer wieder dasselbe Thema.
Genau, aber da, genau in dieser Idee war dann eben die Lobby dieser Jugendschutzprogramme, dieser Einfluss, die genießen eigentlich einen ganz guten Einfluss. Weil diese Alterskennzeichnung wäre nur zum Vorteil dieser Programme gewesen. Und offensichtlich haben die eine ganz gute Lobby, weil wenn jetzt Schröder mit ihrem Kinderschutzzentrum da ankommt und sagt, sie möchte für Jugendschutzprogramme werben, dann ist das klar, dass es im Zweifelsfall eben auch kommerzielle Anbieter sind. Sie könnten natürlich auch irgendwie sich darüber Gedanken machen, irgendwie eine offene Infrastruktur dafür zu bieten. Oder man könnte solche Aufgaben auch crowdsourcen, dass man sagt, ich nehme den Jugendschutzfilter vom CCC und spiele den ein in unser quelloffenes Programm. Oder ich vertraue lieber dem Füllboot oder ich vertraue dem Kinderschutzzentrum oder sonst wem. Also solche Lösungen könnte man da ja auch angehen. Aber das ist offensichtlich nicht das, wovon sie spricht, sondern sie möchte halt für bestehende Jugendschutzprogramme eine Kampagne machen.
Auch wenn ihr mir nicht vorstellen könntet, dass der CCC so eine Liste anbietet.
Ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, das wäre dann irgendwie so ein Link nach Dev Null. Link nach Dev Null heißt eine leere Datei.
Genau, ins Nichts.
Das Nichts.
Ja, viel Neues gibt es auch bei dem ewig wehrenden Themenbereich WikiLeaks. Da gab es ja jetzt die erste Verhandlung nach ewigen Zeiten der Inhaftnahme von Herrn Menning.
Genau, das war das Pre-Trial-Hearing. Also es ist irgendwie noch nicht so die richtige Verhandlung, sondern irgendwie nur das Beweis sammeln. Offensichtlich wurde da noch nicht wirklich die Verhandlung eröffnet, aber trotzdem treten da schon Zeugen auf. Das macht man so, vor der eigentlichen Gerichtsverhandlung finden Anhörungen statt.
Aber das ist doch ein Militärgericht, wo das jetzt stattfindet.
Genau, und ich habe jetzt überhaupt nichts. Ich finde, wenn ich jetzt Military Pre-Trial-Hearing google, um irgendwie zu wissen, was der Unterschied ist zwischen einem zivilistischen Pre-Trial-Hearing und einem militärischen Pre-Trial-Hearing, dann bekomme ich von Google im Moment nur alles über Bradley Menning und nichts zur Bedeutung.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass überhaupt über sowas berichtet wird, wahrscheinlich.
Insofern, also es ist ein Pre-Trial-Hearing und dieses Pre-Trial-Hearing begann etwas unglücklich, also unglücklich für Bradley Menning, mit dem Bericht eines Computer-Forensikers, der Datenreste auf Bradley Mennings Festplatte gefunden hat. Und darunter befanden sich also Chatlogs mit Julian Assange, der im Java wohl den schönen Namen DogNet, D-A-W-G-Net at Java CCC hatte. Und auch Teile von eingereichten Materialien, eine Telefonnummer in Island, also sehr eindeutige Indizien bis Beweise dafür, dass es sich hierbei auch wirklich um Julian Assange gehandelt hat. Und dass vor allem Bradley Menning mit ihm Kontakt hatte. Beweise bis Indizien sag ich deshalb, weil er ja eigentlich seine Chats über OTR geführt hat und diese Chatlogs nicht so 100, also das müsste dann noch wirklich mal genau beurteilt werden, welche gerichtliche Verwertbarkeit so eine TXT-Datei auf einem Rechner hat im Ordner Chatlogs. Viele Leute raten ja dazu, dass man bei seinem Instant-Messenger-Client diese Chatlogs auch ausschaltet, weil man da insgesamt eben über lange Zeit, wenn man so einen Instant-Messenger benutzt, eine ganze Menge Informationen anhäuft, nämlich alles, was man da sich jemals mit einer Person geschrieben hat. Viele nennen das so die kleine Vorratsdatenspeicherung auf der eigenen Platte. Ich denke, würde ich mit jemandem wie Julian Assange einen Jabber-Chat führen, dann hätte ich sicherlich keine Logs an. Also dafür, das ist sicherlich ein Fehler, den der Bradley-Ning gemacht hat.
Das heißt, die ganze Verschlüsselung hat überhaupt nichts bewirkt, weil er hat einfach das Chat-Log unverschlüsselt auf der Platte abgelegt.
Das machen die ja sowieso. Also OTR-Verschlüsselung ist eine End-zu-End-Verschlüsselung über Jabber, die dich aber eigentlich nur dagegen schützt, dass der Jabber-Server dich abhört. Und die eigentlichen Logs, die speichert dein Client, in der Regel dann wieder...
Na, wenn du das eingeschaltet hast.
Genau. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass du... Also ich... Er hat Adium benutzt, das benutze ich auch. Und mir ist nicht bewusst, ob man Adium sagen könnte, speichere bitte die Logs verschlüsselt.
Oder gar nicht halt.
Gar nicht halt. Das kann man machen. Ist sowieso immer die beste Möglichkeit. Was man nicht unbedingt braucht, sollte man auch nicht speichern. Und dann hat er dann noch... Also diese Logs sind irgendwie aufgetaucht und ganz dumm oder ein weiterer Fehler, den Bradley Manning da gemacht hatte, war, dass sie wurden also gefunden im unallocated space der Platte. Das heißt also, wir wissen ja, oder viele von uns wissen das, wenn man eine Datei löscht, wird sie erstmal nicht überschrieben, sondern der Festplatte wird nur gesagt, da wo früher die Datei war, kannst du beim nächsten Mal, wenn du was schreiben möchtest, das da auch hinschreiben.
Genau, wird nur als gelöscht markiert.
Genau, und quasi der gesamte Dateiinhalt findet sich erstmal weiterhin auf dieser Platte. Deswegen, wer Paranoid löschen möchte, überschreibt mindestens drei, empfohlen siebenmal diese Datei abwechselnd mit Nullen, Einsen oder Zufallszahlen oder sonst was. Weil selbst wenn sie einmal überschrieben ist, mit sehr besonderer Computerforensik und sehr viel Mühe, eventuell trotzdem noch dieser Zustand wieder auf den zurückgeschlossen werden könnte. Also man überschreibt Dateien, wenn man sie wirklich weg haben will, mindestens dreimal.
Auch das ist nur ein theoretischer Schutz, muss man dazu sagen. Also das einzige, was eigentlich wirklich hilft, ist eine volle, komplette Verschlüsselung der gesamten Platte und ein Passwort, was sich nicht erraten und im Idealfall auch nicht unbedingt aus einem so ohne Weiteres herauspressen lässt.
Genau, komme ich jetzt aber auch zu, hatte er ja. Genau, er hatte offensichtlich die Verschlüsselung an und da musste ich jetzt in diesem Wired-Attic ein bisschen nachdenken, da stand drin, er hätte das gleiche Passwort für den Zugang zum Rechner gehabt und für den verschlüsselten Teil der Platte. Und er hätte einen MacBook Pro gehabt. Also rechne ich mal damit, dass er 5V anhatte, also die Verschlüsselung des Heimverzeichnisses bei macOS. Und die geht ja quasi gleichzeitig mit auf, wenn man sich mit seinem Benutzernamen einloggt. Das heißt, dass das Passwort für den Zugang zum Computer und die Entschlüsselung der Festplatte ist das gleiche.
Und das war wahrscheinlich jetzt noch kein macOS 10 Lion, was wirklich eine komplette Plattenverschlüsselung anbietet, sondern eben wirklich nur das, was du sagst, die alte Variante, wo man eben nur das Home direkt verschlüsselt.
Genau. Und offensichtlich, es gelang also, diesem Computerforensiker an dieses Passwort irgendwie zu kommen, das ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht allzu schwer, weil es ja irgendwie in irgendeiner nicht besonders sicheren Weise irgendwo auf der Platte irgendwo stecken muss. Aber wie er jetzt genau dran gekommen ist, hat er nicht dazu gesagt, aber vielleicht einfach mal interessant, sich zu merken. Auf jeden Fall konnte er den kompletten Teil entschlüsseln und hat dann im unallocated space Dinge gefunden. Was also Bradley Manning an der Stelle zu empfehlen gewesen wäre, er hätte also erstens keine Chatlocks anhaben sollen für Adium. Und er hätte weiterhin offen vernünftige Verschlüsselungsmethodik, wie jetzt zum Beispiel TrueCrypt mit einem Hidden-Container. Das denke ich mal sind vielleicht eher sinnvolle Möglichkeiten und einem natürlich einem anderen Passwort als dem, was zum Zugriff auf diese Datei notwendig ist. Da hätte er sich vielleicht einen größeren Gefallen mitgetan.
Ja, aber er hätte den Paranoia-Level da sicherlich noch steigern können.
Ja, was mich ein bisschen verwundert ist, vor einiger Zeit wurden ja schon die Chatlocks mit Adrian Lemmo veröffentlicht. Adrian Lemmo ist derjenige, dem Bradley Manning sich gegenüber quasi geoutet hatte und der ihn dann letztendlich auch verpfiffen hat. Im Gespräch mit Adrian Lemmo hatte er eigentlich, haben sie auch ein bisschen über Verschlüsselung und Datensicherheit gesprochen. Da schien der Bradley Manning zumindest eine grobe Ahnung von zu haben. Er hat also irgendwie über verschiedene Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen gesprochen. Insofern ist mir ein bisschen unklar, warum er mit derart brisanten Material so umgegangen ist.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich jetzt nicht für jeden so klar. Vielleicht denkt man in dem Moment auch, er ist ja jetzt kein Computerexperte, oder?
Ja, eigentlich schon. Ich überlege jetzt gerade, was seine genaue Aufgabe war. Es ist ja auch einige Zeit her, dass ich diese Sachen da gelesen habe. Aber der war schon im Sicherheitsbereich da irgendwie... Was steht denn da hier? Was war seine genaue Aufgabe? Also er war Nachrichten-Analyst und war im Umgang mit militärischen Datenbanken. Also ich kann nur sagen, in dem Gespräch mit Adrian Lemmo hat er da irgendwie so auch darüber gesprochen, dass er OTR benutzt beim Chatten und dass er seine Keys regelmäßig rotiert, obwohl das bei also das ist schon besonders paranoid, weil das bei OTR nicht unbedingt notwendigerweise gemacht werden muss, aber also schon natürlich immer schlauer ist zu tun. Aber er hat so ein bisschen in diesen Chats durchaus ein bisschen Kryptokentnisse durchblinken lassen.
Na ja gut, hat auf jeden Fall nicht gereicht, um seine Daten jetzt erfolgreich auch wirklich vor der Analyse zu bewahren.
Ja, mehrere klassische Anfängerfehler eigentlich gemacht. Adrian Lemmo hatten wir gerade ja schon, der hatte also Bradley Manning den Behörden gemeldet. Da kam irgendwie diese Woche raus, dass er zwei Monate später auch einen Jason Katz den Behörden gemeldet hatte. Und dieser Jason Katz hatte von sich behauptet, an der Entschlüsselung des Garani-Videos mitzuarbeiten.
Welches Video ist das?
Ja, das Video kennt glaube ich noch keiner. Und zwar geht es da um den Luftangriff bei Garani. Der fand am 4. Mai 2009 in Westafganistan statt. Und da sind also viele Kampfjets und Bomber irgendwie dann angeblich einen Luftangriff geflogen. Und da kamen laut unterschiedlichen Angaben um die 140 Menschen, darunter Kinder und Frauen, im Bombardement um. Und das ist irgendwie so ein ungeklärter Fall. Der Präsident Afghanistans hatte dann die USA aufgefordert, das zu unterlassen. Hillary Clinton hatte sich entschuldigt, aber irgendwie gibt es da keine ganz klaren Daten zu. Und Julian Assange hatte dieses Video eben angekündigt, dass sie das hätten und dass das irgendwie in diesem Rahmen Beweise liefern könnte. Und dieses Video war aber verschlüsselt. Und sie haben also daran gearbeitet, das irgendwie zu entschlüsseln. Da ist übrigens auch dieser häufige Irrtum wohl geboren worden, dass das Collateral-Mörder-Video irgendwie hätte geknackt werden müssen. Während Daniel Domscheit-Bergke irgendwann auch sagte, dieses Collateral-Mörder-Video, was ja angeblich von Bradley Manning an Wikileaks gekommen ist, da lag ein Passwort bei, das konnten wir ganz einfach entschlüsseln, das mussten wir nicht knacken. Und dieses Garani-Video, das ist also verschlüsselt und das lag da eben auch offensichtlich rum. Und jetzt hatte dieser Adrian Lemmo, ist eben an die Information gekommen, dass dieser Jason Katz sich darum bemüht, hätte diese Datei irgendwie zu entschlüsseln. Und der war eingestellt beim Brookhaven National Laboratory und das ist irgendwie dem Energieministerium unterstellt gewesen. Und dann hat der Lemmo also den Behörden wieder den Tipp gegeben, pass mal auf, hier, der scheint da irgendwie mit Wikileaks dieses Video zu entschlüsseln. Und dann haben die seinen Arbeitsplatzrechner durchsucht und da diese Datei gefunden. Und offensichtlich wurde dann auch tatsächlich durchs Militär bestätigt, dass es sich um diese Datei handelte. Bis jetzt war es aber noch niemandem gelungen, dieses Passwort zu knacken. Und jetzt hat dieser Jason Katz auf jeden Fall Probleme. Auch wieder dank eines Tipps von Adrian Lemmo, aber auch in Verbindung mit natürlich sehr großen Fehlern in der Sicherheit. Ja, also bei meinem Arbeitsplatzrechner. Er wurde auch sowieso dann gefeuert, schon kurz nachdem dieser Hinweis von Adrian Lemmo kam. Und dann das irgendwie auf dem Arbeitsplatzrechner irgendwie zu machen, das sind also wirklich sehr, ja, das sind sehr schluderige Fehler.
Ja, das versteht man nicht. Also das ist ja wirklich, da komm ich gar nicht hinterher. Also wie kann man so nachlässig sein? Naja, gar nicht so einfach, das Bissellblower-Geschäft. Das hat ja auch Julian Assange gemerkt. Letztes Jahr stand ja noch aus, die Entscheidung über die Annahme der Revision am Supreme Court, die über seine Auslieferung entscheiden soll, die ist jetzt gefallen.
Februar soll es losgehen.
Zu seinen Gunsten. Also es gibt jetzt noch mal eine Revision, der wird jetzt nicht gleich an Schweden ausgeliefert. Und dann ist das aber auch, glaube ich, die letzte Stufe. Also was auch immer der Supreme Court dann entscheidet, das wird es dann sein.
Also ich weiß nicht, an wen er sich dann noch vielleicht wenden möchte. Vielleicht an die katholische Kirche oder irgendein Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte. Aber danach sollte dann auf jeden Fall mal das Thema endlich vom Tisch sein.
Trotzdem bleiben sie aktiv und haben jetzt irgendwie auch noch einen... Da muss ich sagen, da habe ich schon so ein bisschen gezuckt mit der Brauer. Also da wusste ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau, wie das jetzt gemeint ist. Ein soziales Netzwerk für Unterstützer von WikiLeaks. Friends of WikiLeaks. Was abgekürzt Fowl heißt und irgendwie dann auch noch mit dieser Friends of WikiLeaks, also auch noch diese Assoziation mit Deadman Don't Wear Plate. Großartiger Film, ja. So Enemies of Carlotta, Friends of Carlotta. Ja, okay. Und dann auch noch ein Social Network. Also das, wo man irgendwie so gemeinhin weiß, das sind jetzt mal genau die Strukturen, an denen eigentlich die Leute, die hinter WikiLeaks her sind, besonders interessiert sind und da sollen jetzt irgendwie alle da rein. Was hast du irgendwie schon verstanden, was jetzt hier ein Glauben machen soll, dass das eine gute Idee ist?
Also, man könnte, vielleicht können wir versuchen, mal erst die Pro-Argumente zu sammeln, weil das geht schneller. Danach kommt dann der Haufen der Kontrast. Also Pro wäre natürlich, wenn WikiLeaks, sag ich mal, diesen Server betreibt und der irgendwie keine Logs hat und so weiter, da kann zumindest WikiLeaks sicherstellen, wie es mit dem Datenmodell und der Datensicherheit in diesem Social Network sich zu verhalten hat. Also sie könnten also theoretisch da eine Infrastruktur aufstellen, die bei Beschlagnahme oder sonst was oder bei einem Hack nichts Ernsthaftes, nichts Nennenswertes zu verraten droht. Sie bündeln vielleicht ein bisschen dann in dieser, nehmen wir einmal an, dass sie sicherer wäre, in dieser sicheren Infrastruktur diese Menschen und schaffen denen eine Möglichkeit, sich da auseinanderzusetzen und das nicht irgendwie auf Facebook zu tun, wo sie sofort verdammt wären. Das wären also die hypothetischen Pro-Argumente. Kontra-Argumente, ich meine, sie schaffen damit so den Topf, wo jetzt alle hinwollen. Das Ding, was jetzt alle angreifen werden, das Ding, wo keiner dem anderen trauen kann, weil da jeder FBI-Agent der CIA oder sonst was, das Ding wird hauptsächlich von denen da wahrscheinlich bevölkert werden.
Die haben sich jetzt alle schon mal in den Account geklickt.
Dann können sie im Zweifelsfall dann nicht für die Sicherheit dieser Sachen garantieren, weil dafür hätten sie, also für eine annehmbare Datensicherheit, hätten sie eine dezentrale Lösung anstreben müssen.
Oder zumindest eine verifizierbare Open-Source-Lösung, was sich aber auch so ein bisschen widerspricht, weil am Ende weiß man ja nicht, welcher Code wirklich da läuft und weiß nicht, welche Bugs da greifen. Ja, ich meine, ich hab das nur so grob überflogen, aber so diese dynamische Gruppenbildung soll ja da auch ein bisschen anders funktionieren. Es geht jetzt nicht darum, dass du da 1000 Freunde hast und da einen Statuspost hast, sondern du hast irgendwie so kleine Gruppen von Aktivisten, die du dann zu irgendwelchen Taten anleiten oder anraten kannst. Und wenn die dann das halt irgendwie nicht tun, dann schmeißt du die wieder raus und suchst sie dir andere. Also so ein bisschen so ein Meritokratie-Auswahl-Verfahren. Ich kann jetzt nicht zugeben, das wirklich schon vollständig verstanden zu haben. Ich frage mich nur, ob das eigentlich wirklich jetzt das ist, was dieses Projekt gebraucht hat. Ich meine, sie starten ein Social-Network, haben aber noch nicht mal die ureigenste Funktion von Wikileaks wiederhergestellt. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, kann man derzeit immer noch nicht auf den Upload-Button klicken und irgendwie Sachen dahin schicken, was eigentlich mal so ursprünglich die Idee war.
Also es ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr komisch. Dann sagen sie auch noch irgendwie, ja, wir werden deine Daten nicht verkaufen. Da bin ich ja dankbar. Also das wäre dann auch noch, eigentlich könnte man ja so ausgerechnet bei denen, die immer all den Scheiß raushauen, bei denen soll ich jetzt irgendwie in Social Network gehen. Also dann sind noch so sehr komische Sachen, die da in diesem Manifest oder was faul ist, steht dann irgendwie noch als letzter Satz, faul wird von dir betrieben. Nee, das ist eben nicht der Fall. Ja, also was sie, was, all den Files irgendwie, wenn man jetzt sagen möchte, man möchte als Wikileaks ein Social Network empfehlen, dann wäre eben der, die Empfehlung natürlich irgendwie jeder einen eigenen Diaspora-Server zu betreiben, ja, und irgendwie nur im Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt zu kommunizieren. Also was weiß ich, ein OTR auf seine Diaspora zu werfen, aber grundsätzlich stellt sich erst mal die Frage, was spricht gegen Java, also OTR über Java ist nach heutigem Kenntnisstand eine sehr vernünftige Lösung, um zu kommunizieren, solange man nicht am Ende, nachdem man über SSL mit dem Java-Server kommuniziert und durch dieses SSL OTR end-to-end-encryption mit dem Key von seinem Gesprächspartner macht, weil man dem Java-Server nicht traut.
Ja, aber hört ihr zu, ich meine, jetzt sind wir schon wieder voll im Techno-Bebble. Und ich bin mir eben nicht so sicher, ob jetzt wirklich alle potenziellen Zuträger einfach das notwendige Know-how da mit sich bringen. Vielleicht missen sie das. Vielleicht ist das die Grundvoraussetzung. Vielleicht ist es einfach nur was für Zuträger, die auch die entsprechende technische Expertise haben. Klar, dann kann man sagen, dass das irgendwie reicht. Aber wie wir gesehen haben, bei dem Mening-Beispiel, kleine Fehler, irgendein falsch gesetztes Flag, können das eben dann schon komplett konterkarieren.
Genau.
Knifflig. Also die Whistleblower-Geschichte bleibt nach wie vor wünschenswert, aber ist schwierig. Ich finde auch, dass das gesamte Gebaren von Wikileaks, das ist einfach alles auch so dermaßen over the top und alles so extrem in seinen Auseinandersetzungen und Querschlägen, die es hat. Und vielleicht ist das alles nur auch das Ergebnis der Verfolgung, schwer zu beurteilen. Aber es bleibt ein fader Beigeschmack.
Ja, also was noch? Also dieses faul ich, ja das ist glaube ich.
Ein fauler Beigeschmack.
Dann wollen sie noch eine E-Mail-Adresse und Kontakt-Details haben und so. Das ist alles nicht sehr gesund. Ja, die Linke, die Partei Die Linke hat jetzt auch ein Grundsatzprogramm. Und betont darin, dass Netz als freie, offene Infrastruktur fordert eine Grundversorgung, Netzneutralität und möchte die dezentrale Struktur des Internets erhalten, die sie nämlich bedroht sieht durch privatwirtschaftliche Oligopole und staatliche Überwachungsinteressen. Prinzipiell machen sie da, also wir hatten das jetzt denke ich mal, wir hatten das ja letztes Mal schon bei den Grünen irgendwie größer besprochen, wir hatten das bei der SPD besprochen, wir hatten, gut bei den Piraten ist das grundsätzlich erstmal klar, wie da die Positionierung ist. Was ich ganz interessant finde, ist, was natürlich dann von den Linken dann auch betont wird, eben zu sagen, ja, dass das irgendwie unser Netz ist, ja, und dass sie also irgendwie möchten, dass das dann auch in der Hand der Menschen ist und dass sie vielleicht auch einfach mal da durchaus ein Phänomen beim Namen nennen, dass eben diese Wirtschaft auch sich dieses Internetz da aneignet und da irgendwie diese Idee, dass die dezentrale Struktur des Internets durch die Zentralisierungstendenz wirtschaftlicher Angebote bedroht wird, das kann man auf jeden Fall sehr klar sehen. Die Frage ist, wie jetzt ausgerechnet dagegen etwas genommen getan werden soll, außer dass man eben dezentrale Kommunikations- und Kontaktmöglichkeiten fördert und lobt. Aber wir hatten ja gerade schon gesagt, hattest du mich darauf hingewiesen, dass es eben sehr viel komplizierter immer ist. Also wenn ich mir meine encrypted Javas einrichte, dann habe ich damit mehr zu tun, muss mehr verstehen, als wenn ich mir einen Account bei faul klicke.
Ich meine, die Linken machen jetzt eigentlich das, was auch die Grünen und ein Stück weit auch die SPD gemacht hat. Das ist ja auch alles servitionswert. Sie haben jetzt alle dieses Jahr eingesehen, dass sie jetzt das Thema Internet in irgendeiner Form auch in ihre Grundsatzdebatte einbringen müssen. Ich denke, hier lässt sich jetzt noch nicht so sehr viel Konkretes ablesen. Für mich ist das eher erstmal ein grundlegendes Positionieren und an der Stelle hören offensichtlich die Parteien zumindest im linken Spektrum auch jetzt mal auf die Leute, die wahrscheinlich schon seit zwei, drei Jahren da den Finger einmal erhoben haben und gesagt haben, hört uns doch mal zu, wir können uns auch selber in der Lage, einen Computer anzuschalten, wir können uns auch einloggen und wissen, wie man eine Suchmaschine benutzt und das sind vermutlich jetzt einfach die Leute, die diese grundlegenden Positionierungen im Kontext der Grundüberzeugung dieser Partei formulieren und das wird dann eben jetzt auch mal angenommen. Ich meine, das ist ja alles sehr richtig, aber auch sehr unkonkret, aber im Grundsatzprogramm ist eben auch einfach unkonkret, so formuliert erst mal das größere Gut, dass man jetzt hier gleich die Oligopole mit ranzieht. Gut, da würde mich jetzt mal interessieren, was Sie da jetzt primär eigentlich sehen. Also ist das jetzt hier, wovon reden Sie? Reden Sie von Facebook und Google? Oder reden Sie von Kabelnetzbetreibern?
Wahrscheinlich meinen Sie sogar beides. Also einfach nur, um es festzuhalten, wir wollen das ja so ein bisschen vielleicht auch irgendwann noch mal darauf zurückgreifen, wie eben einzelne Parteien sich so positioniert haben.
Und im Moment gibt es auf jeden Fall erst mal eine Positionierung, das Herr Schmark.
Und die ist erst mal nicht großartig zu kritisieren aus liberaler Perspektive. Und dann haben wir noch so ein kleines Thema, die Bundes-Cloud. Wir wollen die Bundes-Cloud haben. Also vielleicht ganz kurz Cloud-Computing, der neue oder in den letzten Jahren der große Trend. Auch hier etwas, was sagen wir mal ein bisschen dieser dezentralen Idee des Netzes eigentlich wieder strebt, ist also die Idee, dass man seine Daten zentral bei bestimmten Diensten ansiedelt. Also klassischer Cloud-Service ist also Dropbox, wo ich meine Dateien automatisch werden, die von meiner Festplatte in die Dropbox synchronisiert. Dort kann ich über Dropbox zum Beispiel einen Ordner mit Tim teilen und da die Notizen für das Logbuch Netzpolitik immer reinschreiben, ich speicher sie auf meiner Festplatte und sie werden automatisch dann auf Tims, in Tims Dropbox und in Tims Festplatte aktualisiert. Ich könnte mit Apple iCloud meine Adressbücher und Kalender zwischen iPad, iPhone, MacBook und iMac synchronisieren und habe immer den gleichen Kalender, weil der zentrale Kalender eigentlich bei Apple liegt und die Daten dort gespeichert sind.
Ja, an sich ist das ja auch alles sehr wünschenswert, sowas will man ja irgendwie haben. Es ist immer nur die Frage, wie sehr man den jeweiligen Betreibern da vertraut in Hinsicht auf Privatsphäre und in Hinsicht auf Datensicherheit, weil das Versprechen mit deine Daten bleiben und uns erhalten. Da sind ja auch die ein oder anderen Hersteller schon mal darüber gestolpert. Ja, also was ich hier dieses Sidekick-Desaster bei Microsoft, was sie dann nach einer Weile dann immer noch zumindest noch partiell wieder gerettet haben, aber es zeigt sich halt schnell, dass da eben auch sehr zuverlässig gearbeitet werden muss. Klar. So, und was für jetzt die Bundesregierung?
Ja, jetzt meldete sich dann das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik und sagt, naja, vor allem die meisten Cloud-Angebote stehen in den USA und die geben, die können ja wegen der Anti-Terror-Gesetze zum Herausgeben der Daten gezwungen werden. Und das wäre ja irgendwie nicht besonders fein und deswegen sollte man sich ja überlegen, ob man jetzt deutsche Firmen, ist ja auch für Firmen interessant, solche Cloud-Sachen, ob man unbedingt seine Daten jetzt in den USA ablegen möchte oder ob man das nicht dann vielleicht besser in Baden-Württemberg macht. Genau. Wo dann der deutsche Staat dann Zukunft hat.
Die Bedürfnisse des deutschen Staates liegen sicherlich ganz woanders.
Genau, und dafür möchte jetzt das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik so eine Art deutsches Cloud-Zertifikat machen, also die wollen quasi Angebote zertifizieren. So dass quasi ein Anbieter sagt, ich mach jetzt hier Cloud und ich bin zertifiziert nach BSI-Richtlinie so und so. BSI hat auch bei mir geprüft, dass ich deren Vorgaben einhalte und damit habe ich jetzt die zertifizierte Cloud und die Telekom ist da sehr interessiert und sagt, ja Mensch, das finden wir ganz toll.
Was ist da gesagt worden, über was diese Zertifizierung beinhalten soll?
Ja, da hat man noch nicht so richtig hundertprozentig was zu gesagt. Nicht, das ist ja überraschend. Was diese Zertifizierung sein soll, nicht so wirklich. Es steht, das BSI soll nachher nach bestimmten Schutzprofilen und Vorgaben Anbieter von Cloud-Speicherlösungen zertifizieren. Und dann sollen die Unternehmen auf den ersten Blick sehen können, ob ein Anbieter den staatlichen Sicherheitsempfehlungen Folge leistet.
Also sie wollen auch eine Kopie haben und das lassen sie sich dann zertifizieren.
Ich denke nicht, dass das offiziell so beim BSI offen so da drin stehen hätte. Aber ich würde mich zum Beispiel auch wundern, wenn das BSI eine Lösung zertifizieren würde, die beinhaltet, dass die Dateien, also es ist ja relativ einfach möglich, so speichere ich beispielsweise Dateien in der Cloud. Ich nutze ja beispielsweise auch Dropbox. Was ich aber mache, ist, ich habe einen vorherigen Filter davor, der die Dateien verschlüsselt. Das heißt also, meine Dateien in der Dropbox sind alle verschlüsselt mit einem Schlüssel, der nur mir bekannt ist und der auch nur bei mir zu Hause auf meinem Rechner liegt. Das heißt, wenn die USA mich dann irgendwann als Terroristen erkennen, dann finden sie in meiner Dropbox mit aktuellem Verschlüsselungsstandard verschlüsselte Dateien, mit denen sie im Zweifelsfall erst mal nichts anfangen können sollten. Das wäre natürlich, wenn das BSI jetzt sagen würde...
Womit du deinen Terroristenstatus dann aber wahrscheinlich auch bestätigt hast.
Genau, womit ich das dann auch wirklich die Einreisebedingungen zementiert habe. Das wäre natürlich also eine quasi eine Verschlüsselung dieser Form in der Cloud. Das wäre natürlich etwas, was ich als allererstes in so eine Zertifizierungsrichtlinie schreiben würde. Nämlich sagen, die Cloud selber speichert nur Müll, mit dem dort niemand etwas anfangen kann. Und ich bezweifle oder ich wäre sehr überrascht, wenn das BSI das jetzt als Teil dieser Zertifizierung aufnehmen würde. Und sagen würde, wir zertifizieren nur, wenn euer System beinhaltet, dass eure Cloud nur verschlüsselte Daten aufnimmt. Und damit dieser gesamte Festplattenplatz, den ihr da zur Verfügung stellt, für euch in keiner Form irgendwie im Zugriff ist. Wie das beispielsweise, ich meine, dass Waller von sich behauptet, das so zu tun. Und ich bezweifle, dass das BSI sowas in seiner Richtlinie am Ende drinstehen haben wird. Wenn sie das da drinstehen haben werden, dann würde ich mich sehr freuen und wäre auch sehr erfreut, wenn es dann Anbieter gäbe, die diese Zertifizierung dann auch umsetzen und mir die Möglichkeit geben, naja, zumindest darauf zu vertrauen, dass mir die Behauptung, mir gegenüber die Behauptung gemacht wurde, dass das geschehe. Tatsächlich nachprüfen kann man es ja dann eh nur bei einer Open-Source-Software oder wenn man es eben wie immer selber macht.
Gut, also der Plan bleibt noch unklar. Auf jeden Fall geht es jetzt, ich meine, es ist immer von der Bundes-Cloud die Rede. Das ist eigentlich vollkommen irreführend. Es geht jetzt hier nicht um die eigene Errichtung einer Bundeswolke. Man könnte vielleicht im weiteren Sinne noch vermuten, ja, dass ich hier mal wieder die, also es ist eine kleine Unterstellung, aber kann ja durchaus sein, dass die deutsche Wirtschaft langsam in den Zug abfahren sieht, was so die ganze Cloud-Geschichte betrifft und dass sich die Unternehmen hier gerade nicht in den letzten zehn Jahren damit auseinandergesetzt haben. Infrastrukturen sich auszudenken, die irgendwie zuverlässig laufen, also zumindest nicht large scale mit Millionen von Usern gleichzeitig in rentablen Datenzentren, für die hier vermutlich noch nicht mal die bezahlbare Energie vorhanden wäre, um sie zu betreiben. Dass sie sich da jetzt doch furchtbar abgehängt fühlen. Ob jetzt so eine Initiative an der Stelle allerdings eine große Hilfe wäre, weiß ich auch nicht.
Also es wird noch argumentiert, dass viele deutsche Unternehmen aus Sicherheitsbedenken noch nicht auf Cloud-Dienste setzen.
Andererseits aber wahrscheinlich alle jetzt auch setzen wollen.
Das ist natürlich einfach eine Grafik, die ich aber nicht sehe. So vertrauen nur wenige Unternehmen sensible Daten der Cloud an. Ja, das ist auch richtig so, liebe Unternehmen. Da bleibt mal bei. Und jetzt also genau T-Systems, was mir noch nicht so richtig bekannt war. Also Telekom Systems ist im Moment der größte deutsche Cloud-Anbieter und wäre auch der größte Profiteur. Also was ich da jetzt so ein bisschen raussehe, ist, dass deutsche Cloud-Anbieter irgendwie sehen, okay, es läuft irgendwie erstens nicht so gut wie in den USA. Und zweitens haben die Firmen Sicherheitsbedenken. Na, wie wär's denn, wenn das BSI uns da mal irgendwie ein Stempel draufdrückt?
So nach dem Motto, dass es hier testet und approved und nur so was dürft ihr, solltet ihr auch nur verwenden. Na klar könnt ihr zu Facebook und zu Amazon gehen, aber da ist ja nicht der Stempel drauf.
Genau. Und solche Stempel sind natürlich grundsätzlich nicht zu trauen. Schwierige Sache, es riecht da wieder so ein bisschen nach Aktionismus. Nach Aktionismus und irgendwie auch hier nach einer Sache, wo wahrscheinlich nicht oder wo hoffentlich nichts vernünftiges bei rauskommt.
Ja, die Bundeswolke wird noch eine Weile auf sich warten lassen. Bundeswolken kokosheim allerdings hat man den Eindruck, das gibt es schon.
So sieht es aus.
Haben wir es, wa?
Wir haben es.
Für diese Woche.
Für dieses Jahr.
Genau. Also das war es jetzt hier mit dem normalen Logbuch. Und vielleicht gibt es noch ein paar Sonderausgaben, mal gucken. Ansonsten, nächstes Jahr gibt es wieder weiter wöchentliche Updates. Tschüss.